Egypt after the Arab Spring what hopes
for peace in the interview Egyptian
Foreign Minister Naveen [ __ ] me my
little sister [ __ ] me diplomatic ties
between the EU and Egypt have cooled
considerably since the ouster of
President Mohammed Morsi how would you
describe the current state of relations
hey Leo so far but nah I wouldn't say
relationship cooled but many questions
have been asked what happened in Egypt
was very important he had a second major
event within two and a half years over
the last few months the relations he
referred to have become much more
defined Egypt is driving to improve
relations of the EU there shall mas will
be Matt baina must remain a daughter of
P now Phil hadith under the EU and
Germany have repeatedly called for a
national reconciliation in Egypt they
said no political groups should be
excluded that'll do the EU and Germany
have a role to play in helping Egyptians
overcome their differences while a site
hadeel masala Neoga door hey it's art of
nabi fee foreign entities actually have
no place in domestic Egyptian affairs
mean their own Egyptian decisions must
be the will of the Egyptian people in a
local waheeda the one thing other
nations can help with is building a
working democracy based on international
norms that's nothing new but other
decisions should be made by us alone
sofa ll Khalil is the main hindrance to
reconciliation of em and is that a
number of groups have resorted to
violence isn't so they've essentially
ostracized themselves have been ahead
that they are the problem doesn't stem
from animosity between these groups in
the government it's a conflict among the
people we now have a constitution and
those who observe it and renounce
violence will find their niche in Egypt
in fee and Siham ously now Jim and how
does one anjuman Egypt has declared the
muslim brotherhood a terrorist
organization what will happen to its
followers will they obtain a role in the
political process jamaat al muslimeen
ani k film terminal de la havana to show
danville ammonia CSU I'm gonna be a man
yelling at all tatuaje gonna tunnel
anyone who resorts to violence operates
outside the law again attacks on public
buildings and places will be treated as
terrorism and all in here that's all
that matters deal with us all political
groups must adhere to the laws laid down
in the Constitution but we know there
are two distinctions in Egypt we have
political Islamist movements and they
can exercise their rights one is the
HISP and or party in terms of the Muslim
Brotherhood we'll have to discuss what
they've done since june the 30th
wondered if they returned to the center
then Egyptians can decide for themselves
but only if they act responsibly and no
longer have blood on their hands and
your clever either Sedaka pick in the
world next to come have to tell you he's
it well and about that had to sign man
lays out ID him damn it now maybe had
you thought what about Salafist groups
such as his run north it's hard for some
in the West to understand why the
Egyptian government has chosen to
cooperate in some areas with this party
it's considered more extreme than the
Muslim Brotherhood Lena model son left a
madman muslimeen Kazuma how do you
explain this seeming paradox shaded it
proves that the Egyptian government and
society as a whole embrace democracy
democracy allows for a broad array of
opinions opposing ideas can become part
of discourse as long as they are
represented peacefully that if branding
the Muslim Brotherhood as terrorists has
little to do with the revolution on jun
the 30th blacks we actually asked them
to take part in a reconciliation
commission on malignantly Mustafa they
declined the offer latina cuddle either
mal'chik know so i will have you some
odwalla what I can come with Alex well I
look from all the word how about freedom
of the press re rad phim human rights
groups have expressed concern about
freedom of expression in egypt tunisia
kesava bharati laheera bill hadith on al
Jazeera journalists and other bloggers
have been detained tellin
what's your reaction a career in halacha
cocl is eaten with Murphy's Alec alone
for interfere along the ongoing violence
in Egypt probably led to some
unfortunate situations ma has mayor
mayor Mallory but our government and
courts protect the freedoms and basic
rights of journalists mean were not just
a few days ago our government issued a
declaration welcoming the presence of
foreign journalists and ensuring their
rights to work in home PR men home as
long as they are accredited and observe
Egyptian law okay cool melodia and our
courts set 60 people free but among them
journalists shot and one al-jazeera
corresponding to be my film Sophie I had
a home any giddy telethon wagon had had
the found the trial of deposed President
Mohammed Morsi is under wagon one of the
charges has to do with his escape from
prison three years ago SS in a wet lima
Dylan Yucca Valley muah why wasn't he
charged before he ran for president
rally or even once he took office again
I wouldn't opt on e and a beheading foto
con tu bata I wasn't part of the
government back then so I have no way of
commenting on things that didn't happen
happen theories acerbic Marcia there are
a number of charges against the former
president was his escape from prison is
just one of many a few Cavill and there
were no stuff I did some investigating
on my own and discovered that the
investigation was ongoing and
prosecutors cannot level charges while
an investigation is ongoing trouble and
you've got your segment at the thief
nominal hadith on Egypt's interior
ministry recently accused turkey of
complicity and terrorist attacks in
Cairo Egypt has also warned Qatar to
stop interfering in Egyptian affairs how
much interference is there and do you
have hard evidence that Turkey might
have been involved in terrorist attacks
cookie edible might be idea to Jared a
man to shitty latest fear no see blamed
had this investment you are referring to
comments to the press made by a
spokesman for the interior ministry
I won't comment about those in detail
mar 1 Marlin fidelium but there have
been enough press reports that the
international Muslim Brotherhood met
several times in Turkey are the
americano mostly mean many of those
meetings ended with anti Egyptian
resolutions mind again and so if the
interior ministry comments are valid
perhaps they were referred to that but
you can't have the whole box would be
the Fiat lessly I guess I can build fire
at this yes so that as far as Qatar is
concerned it's part of the Arab world
don't worry we were expecting a
different reaction from Qatar and we
hope that it rethinks some of its
positions and match ahead now it would
be unacceptable to harm Egypt when it is
already in a delicate political
situation in it might s beam us we
simply cannot tolerate that yessir
scattered must ask what kind of
relations at once with the Arab world
one fulfill SS will a Tonka tina quinn
mcmullen Helen it must well here I hope
it considers and proceeds to change its
views and you're going to Antigua the
press has reported that qatar has made
disparaging comments about egypt but
they've said the same things about
Bahrain Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates el-hadji Sian shed bloggers ow
malcolm Shelby the cutter Heather when I
get off my land it's not about qatar
versus Egypt Jennifer it's about a
country that has gone against all other
Arab nations he's man neca Saudi nafsa
Hadees ma in mrs kelly motive is Elmo's
la ley said cutter cutter needs to
rethink its position he'll your column
heart and the wound out ledee still
affect my cool de dólar me oh hello Kim
dune and the phone or neck sheet yes
tell America now we'll have you cite an
unlit have been a terrorist groups have
taken up arms against Egyptian security
forces what they possess explosives and
guns where are they getting their
weapons
kahan ambassador heading las llantas a
lady's Amidala ischia dia omaha dirt
Emilio mesodermal telephone number of
sources was him in him in Libya was
imminent some are being smuggled from
Libya with I see through the
Mediterranean what was he gay Chuck some
is supplied by the west and was the sum
from the east we're headed a second em
morsel we see a broad array of weaponry
and large amounts have been confiscated
sir hat hermina so some arrives from
lawless regions in the yeast and some
from Libya which is increasingly
unstable and in here lady she had now is
an icon of Cathy you but we will not
give into terrorism and then whether in
the Sinai or the Nile Delta V seen yet
women banded early oh but the resume
their liquid built now an illusion dhola
mojada there's a cattleman that estimate
that you don't suspect anyone country
how will double my na talking for that I
don't tough how much they really do it
any it I mean sir a number of entities
are involved not just countries yes the
weapons come from regions in various
nations really said later for some of
the exports are made by government's
that support international terrorist
groups I'm not specifically singling out
Libya and how many be a clock and I'm
not saying that the government there is
supporting international terrorism
defect cook feel better it's just that
the security situation there is not
under control forgiving so weapons are
smuggled out neck Teletubby rd de
further east we're a great many
terrorist organizations are poring arms
into egypt we know that by the type of
weapon is my Anna we can only judge on a
case-by-case basis where the nations are
involved in the smuggling they're the
cool dad as Maggie's yep there's not
many names let this mate ain't even doin
feel like a fatty no so what about the
presidential candidacy of Abdel Fattah
el-sisi he's not a candidate yet bad
that fellow the military council
expressed the hope that he would run in
Yetta will Alaska remember I was bad do
you fear that the military is becoming
the chief power broker in Egypt a fat
road una let him L machine sec if Field
Marshal al-sisi does decide to run into
president he will receive broad support
from the Egyptian people no observer can
deny this hydroponic monster there will
certainly be other candidates but they
are not familiar to the public smell in
them up but with all due respect and in
all honesty and what's happening in
Egypt is far too important Emma it's not
about any one person was we have a
society that refuses to give up its
freedom of expression asthma and every
future president will be responsible for
upholding the Constitution if elected
but as I said here but much more is at
stake here than any single individual
unborn muchas molly was mr. [ __ ] me
thank you thank you